bonjour johan ville rose
directeur-général du pnr end le parc
naturel régional de la martinique
jon videront s'il ya près de quinze
jours le parc naturel a décerné une
labellisation à une quarantaine
d'agriculteurs il y avait une première
vague de 8,1 me semble-t-il
alors vous vous dites que le pnm
poursuit ainsi l'accompagnement
j'insiste sur ce terme l'accompagnement
des agriculteurs afin de valoriser leurs
produits et d'offrir une image
d'excellence de la profession alors
objectif louable sur le papier a priori
mais comment expliquer que le président
de la chambre d'agriculture à cette même
place la semaine dernière continuaient à
se montrer pour le moins réticent sur la
méthode de cette initiative
comment l'expliquer
déjà nous avons le label s'étend il a
été étudié temps pour accompagner les
agriculteurs que pour rassurer les
consommateurs ça c'est un fait c'est un
point important il ya ces deux aspects
alors que le président de la chambre
décide enfin bon ça que je vais pas
revenir sur tout ce qu'il vous a dit
qu'il refuse de l'accompagner c'est un
fait
alors il s'agit aussi d d'harry's et il
a argumenté il ya deux arguments à ses
yeux d'abord c'est que il a l'air de
dire que cette affaire va va trop vite
que du coup moi je vous pose la question
est ce que vous n'avez pas confondu
vitesse et précipitation
voilà parce que c'est vrai qu'entre le
moment où il ya eu la déclaration de
vouloir faire ce label qui a été appuyée
traits assez rapidement d'ailleurs pas
par les services de l'état je t'aurais
fait lui-même s'est s'engagé moi je me
souviens j'avais assisté à la première
réunion
enfin la conférence de presse anp en
préfecture entre le moment ça s'est
déclaré et puis d'ailleurs on a demandé
dans quel délai etc
on l'a dit boyle d'ici six mois huit
mois on vous commencerez à voir les
premiers agriculteurs les premiers
produits labellisés 0 chlordécone ça a
été très vite peut-être même un peu trop
vite aux yeux de
de l'agent de la culture de la chambre
consulaire pour pour être très franc on
parle de croiront pas de notes de risque
énorme sur la santé publique la santé
des pratiques le scandale du chlordécone
jeudi le mot scandale parce que c'est le
moc à l'uqar employés le président de la
république lui-même
la molécule est connu comme extrêmement
toxiques depuis les années 70 en
martinique mais encore jeudi depuis 1993
donc ça fait plus de 20 ans 25 ans il
était temps d'agir
il ya des travaux il y à il ya beaucoup
de travaux on en parle encore niant
toute cette semaine qui ont été faits
qui relèvent quoi qui relève que oui on
reconnaît la toxicité
il ya des choses qui sont faites des
études qui sont menées pour pau pour au
moins essayer de régler ce problème là
et tous les chercheurs s'accordent à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de lisibilité à
moyen terme
que faisons que faisons nous il faut
aujourd'hui le parc
fort de son expertise y avait urgence la
veille mais il vit un véritable il y a
une véritable urgence aujourd'hui les
chercheurs eux-mêmes s'accordent à dire
que quand une population reste non
exposés pendant quatre à cinq ans la
molécule s'élimine donc laissons les
chercheurs faire le travail mais en
attendant il est urgent de ne pas rester
croise les doigts croisés alors louis
daniel berten dit également que bon le
pnm récupère un peu un travail qui a été
fait en amont qui est déjà fait depuis
plusieurs années par la chambre
d'agriculture
et puis voilà on a sorti un peu ce
ce label à 0 au chlordécone d'ailleurs
pourquoi ne pas élargir à zéro pesticide
carrément alors là aussi c'est un grief
qu'on entend dans ses romans on l'entend
souvent
alors oui les chercheurs travaillent
depuis 20 ans il ya maintenant que la
molécule est connu il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été faites
nous n'avons pas la prétention toute
humilité on s'appuie sur ces travaux là
on s'appuie sur l'existant pour proposer
une méthode fiable permettant
d'identifier les produits sans chlore
d'école cia mais c'est il est utile et
urgent aussi d'annoncer qu'il qu'on peut
aujourd'hui produire sans chlordécone
les martiniquais latin nous avons un
total respect pour les agriculteurs mais
que serait t'il sans la confiance de
leurs propres consommateurs une
profession encore plus sinistre et
qu'elle ne l'est déjà
aujourd'hui la le label est ouvert c'est
une démarche qui est volontaire je dis
bien volontaire on ne va on n'impose pas
aux agriculteurs de venir avec nous pour
le dans le processus de labellisation
ils viennent il ya aujourd'hui plus
d'une centaine ils viennent mais c'est
pas comme ça après il ya quand même des
critères mais évidemment c'est à dire à
conakry vous choisissez se disant être
labellisé en effet on a ce qu'on ne
choisit pas sélectionné
c'est à dire qu'il y a cahier des
charges des moments précis et cyril aux
dictateurs qui répond à ce cahier des
charges il normalement la présidence de
la chambre d'agriculture dit également
que comme avec le mouton marque est
d'ailleurs le parc naturel organise une
forme de concurrence entre
professionnels d'un même petit
territoire il dit bon voilà le les
agriculteur de la creuse qui vantent
leurs produits par rapport à telle ou
telle autre région de l'hexagone bon
c'est grand c'est vaste c'est pas trop
grave mais voilà instaurer une institué
une concurrence entre agriculteurs d'un
même petit territoire
c'est pas bon il s'agit pas de
concurrence monsieur cage
il ne s'agit pas de concurrent survient
on parle de l'assassin dès lors on
valorise quelques uns
mais mais mais mais c'est la vie qui est
comme ça des gens on les valorise
pourquoi parce qu'ils font l'effort en
les valorise aussi et les agriculteurs
qui sont avec nous jeudi agriculteurs et
éleveurs ont bien compris la démarche
parce que sur la centaine d'agriculteurs
qui qui ont déjà ça continue on continue
à recevoir dès demain qui ont qui sont
déjà dans le processus
ceux qui sont labellisés compte tout
autant que ceux qui n'ont pas encore pu
obtenir le label
il s'agit de faire quoi d'essayer de
comprendre pourquoi ils n'ont pas le
label est de mettre en place les moyens
qui leur permettront de l'obtenir
et c'est ça qui fondamental pour nous à
terme il s'agit de faire croire il
s'agit pas de créer une concurrence il
s'agira d'accompagner les agriculteurs
pour que qu'on puisse proposer aux
martiniquais des produits qui sont
labellisés sans chlore des codes c'est
bien là le problème il s'agit pas de
deux concurrents s'il s'agit vraiment
d'apporter une solution à un problème
qui existe déjà et je reviens encore sur
le président à moyen ou à long terme on
peut envisager qui très forte majorité
des agriculteurs qu'ils soient
labellisés
si le ccg consommateurs c'est le souhait
des consommateurs les agriculteurs il
suffit de voir simplement les réactions
des agriculteurs qui obtiennent leur
label ils sont profondément ancrés sur
un point ils sont là pour nourrir la
population en leur donnant des produits
ça on reconnaît ce travail là je ne dis
pas que tous les agriculteurs
là il n'y a que les agriculteurs
labellisés qui font ce travail
au contraire il y en a mais il s'agit
aujourd'hui de d'éviter de jeter
l'opprobre sur une profession qui fait
des efforts et surtout de lancer une
tendance vers du zéro et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que dit le président a dit
on continue il ya encore des demandes
qui arrive et c'est vous allez faire une
pause peut-être
je vais pas tenter de fédérer comme vous
le suggère fortement la chambre
d'agriculture ce que vous allez vous
rapprocher à nouveau tenter aussi de
d'en faire un partenaire finalement sur
cet asus et dès le départ nous avons
cherché à fédérer les services de l'état
nous accompagner la foi dont la safer je
vais pas tous les citer les coopératives
font même la chambre a participé nous
avons eu trois réunions de travail avec
la chan dont la dernière où nous avons
plus répondre point par point à une
vingtaine de questions qui nous
opposaient ils ont eu les réponses
aujourd'hui prétendent ne pas les avoir
soit mais je reviens sur un point ce qui
compte pour nous c'est de ces
d'accompagner cédric ces agriculteurs et
surtout de rassurer la population
britannique
vous êtes dans sa au caddie avec johan
videront ce le directeur général du parc
naturel de la martinique vous avez été
nommé enfin vous êtes revenu donc à la
direction générale de cet organisme
il ya quelque temps on se rappelle la
suite à l'épisode fâcheux du
licenciement c'est bien c'est bien ça de
monsieur bri mère alors dites moi depuis
comment ça se passe en interne
opn m il n'y a pas un souci sur la
commission analyse stratégique et
prospective l'une des administratrices
je crois madame litres et vous a adressé
des courriers disons que bon cette
commission ne se réunit pas suffisamment
enfin que voilà alors est encore
quelques remous semble-t-il c'est propre
et m forcément vous savez le parc en
zone est un épisode qui a été
extrêmement bon déjà médiatisé est
extrêmement douloureux
en interne vous demandez aujourd'hui
comment va le parc en général quand on
me pose la question je là je la retourne
vers celui ou celle qui me la posent en
disant quelle perception je préfère
retenir le positif
le parc et s'est engagé dans un certain
nombre de projets structurants pour la
martinique on a parlé du label 0
chlordécone je vais pas tous les citer
martinique merveilles du monde
je préfère aujourd'hui
rester dans le positif et et et rendre
hommage à tous ces agents tous ces élus
qui travaillent dans un intérêt commun
évidemment cette commission analyse
stratégique et prospective
elle a une réunion je crois qu'il est
prévu pour demain 18 octobre dans ce
pôle c'est à 2 ces panneaux mana ne sera
pas de même et elle se tiendrait elle se
tiendra vous vous l'assuré hélas il ne
va pas forcément de la respect d'autrui
j'arrive attaque administratif et
directeur général d'une structure ce
sont des choses qui vont se régler avec
les élus qui vont se voir avec les élus
et donc permettez que je laisse là
encore la primaire je ne vais pas
mélanger les gens là il y a des élus au
parc je respecte profondément leur
travail notamment un président qui qui
qui mobilise l'ensemble de ses élus donc
ça c'est quelque chose que nous allons
on a quelques secondes
dites nous où on en est est ce que ça
évolue positivement
vous savez le projet de l'inscription au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
ça dans la montagne pelée nous sommes ne
soit justement à paris la semaine
prochaine pour la dernière audition au
niveau hexagonal
on va présenter le plan de gestion
justement sûr sûr sûr le ce bien
martiniquais et pour pouvoir justement
c'est la dernière étape avoir une
présentation officielle devant les
instances mondiales février 2018
merci je vais bien merci johan videront
son directeur général du parc naturel
régional de la martinique d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans son caddie
bonne journée
merci à vous